so I'm going to give an illustration for
you it's a it's a beautiful and a
classic proof which I mentioned
Pythagoras before really old by but
stuffing still prude was still true a
little suddenly I'd like you to make is
about another old Greek guy they do a
lot of Max those ancient Greeks called
Euclid
now you could prove you could prove that
you know prime numbers you guys know
what prime knowns are right he proved
that there's an infinite number of prime
numbers that they'll never ever end
which is quite impressive because
scientifically you can't prove that
because you can keep on going and going
and going but they've always might be a
point where it stops so well how do you
know whether we got to that point or not
so this is you could proof for infinite
primes okay so here's the statement
we're going to try and prove statement
there is an infinite number of prime
numbers now I just want to pause for
about 30 seconds I just want you to
think how would you even begin on trying
to prove such a thing when when you see
the word infinite it's very intimidating
because you're like well I can't just go
like with it doesn't matter where you
begin so long as you go in some sort of
straight line you will never get to the
end that's what infinite means right so
how would you go about proving something
like this how could you go about using a
tool like this
I'm going to ask you to help me start
off because you actually have enough
information at least to make the first
step
given this kind of setting right if this
is the way that proof by contradiction
works and this is the first step in any
proof by contradiction then what should
be my first step or what was your good
first step to try and prove this
statement yeah okay so the you've got to
be very careful with the choice of this
but the assumption that this is false
right is that we'll assume there is a
finite number right I can list these out
this is the assumption we're going to
make now in addition to that what I'm
going to do is I'm going to I'm going to
try and like state in mathematical terms
what this might look like right so
suppose these prime numbers I don't know
how many there are but suppose there is
some limited number I should be able to
thinking back to what we thought about
with sequences and series earlier on
this time I should be able to list them
shouldn't I
they're all prime so I'm going to call
them all like something that p1 p2 p3
etc now when you see this dot dot dot
with a sequence if I just left it like
that what would that mean it's Tyrian
okay so these are the only ones I know
about but the dot dot dot indicates
there are ones that I don't know about
and it just sort of keeps going when you
don't end that means it's infinite but
I'm suggesting I'm assuming that there
is an ending right so I'm going to say
there is some nth prime number that is
the last prime number in existence okay
and that number might be huge it might
be billions and billions and billions
but the point is it stops somewhere and
after that no more okay so what I want
to try and do is apply some logic that
will take this assumption and
show that something has gone wrong show
a contradiction with what I've assumed
okay so here was you could stroke of
genius right
what he said was let the introduce any
number let's call it our X let X be the
product of all of these prime numbers so
P 1 times P 2 times P 3 multiply all of
them together all the way up until the
last one and then do something really a
genius with that which is add 1 ok now
remember what he's trying to do he's
trying to show that in fact this year
this assumption is going to lead to a
problem so I'm assuming this into the
complete list right if I can prove that
it's not a complete list then I've got a
sort of self contradictory situation and
that will be the proof ok now let's
start to make this a little bit easier
for our brains to consider maybe off on
the side or with another color if you've
got it I want you to imagine what this
list could be suppose the list was this
3 5 7 okay all I shall have to other
virtually okay so suppose this was the
entire list of prime numbers right um
what would X be if this is the list
that's not a um rhetorical question what
would actually expect 2 times 3 times 5
times 7 will be 6 times 5 which is 30
times 7 which is 210 but then I add 1
yes to be 211 ok now think about this
with me think about what a prime number
is like what defines a prime number what
is a prime number actually what makes a
prime number Prime on the income okay so
the very common and helpful definition
is a number that's divisible by 1 and
itself because this is not a prime
number and I'll come to the reasons why
in another lesson this is a prime number
according to your definition even though
that's a very good way
define it so we actually slightly
tweaked it and we say prime numbers are
the ones that exactly two factors
exactly two not more and not less it has
less than two thousand three now if
that's the case that's what makes a
prime number I want you to have a look
at 211 for a second
there's 211 divided into two nice and
neatly it doesn't of course it character
that's odd
what about into three it can't either
now I mean the visibility test for three
is very easy you like you look at the
digits in that company but you don't
even need to do the test to know that it
can't be divisible by three can you tell
me why because I added one right I'd
have to add three or six or nine in
order to get to the next divisible by
three number for the same reason it
can't be divisible by five or seven
right so what does that mean about this
number what can you tell me about this
number 211 is either and this is
actually important it's one of two
things
as Emily suggested maybe it's prime
because it doesn't seem to divide by
anything on my list and remember I said
I have all of the primes right I said
I've got them all okay so is it prime if
it's prime my assumption was wrong I
don't have the complete list does that
make sense
so I've already come into a problem
there is one other alternative 211 is a
big number
maybe it's divisible by something else
right if it's divisible by something
else then what does that mean about this
list it's it's still not complete right
so this might be divisible by a like it
might not be prime 211 might not be
prime but might be divisible by some
other prime in both of these cases I'm
in trouble because both of these cases
suggest that this what list as it
clearly isn't isn't complete does that
make sense so if this is what X is how
am I going to state this right
X cannot be divisible by any of the
numbers on this list cannot be divisible
by P 1 comma P 2 P 3 etc or P n right
and the reason why this ingenious thing
that you could did he did this right
that breaks the divisibility no matter
what combination of numbers you put
together okay
that's why 211 comput is about two three
five or seven and no matter how long
this list is I can always do the trick
and come up with a new number that you
always have a remainder of one right in
fact this is something we can say there
will always be a remainder of one okay
therefore therefore X is one of these
two possibilities right is either a
prime number itself or divisible by some
other prime that's not on the list
and you can see in either of these two
possible cases for 211 or whatever
number X actually is because it would be
much larger obviously whatever each of
these is my original assumption up here
has just been contradicted okay
so therefore one more flow of logic my
original assumption is false the
Assumption must be false the list is not
complete and what's lovely about this is
we can keep on playing this forever it
doesn't matter how big n is and could be
billions trillions Google's Google Plex
is long and you can still do this trick
it might take you a while but it will
still be just as true as when we did it
with just four numbers okay so now this
is incomplete there is an infinite
number of primes now oops there we go
you can see how you can use this tool in
a whole variety of ways you can use it
to prove something like the angle sum of
triangle as well fairly easily excuse me
but the reason why you haven't been
exposed to before is because clearly
this is a more direct way of doing
things if it's possible right if it's
possible it's like well just let's just
live in a world where things are true
that's a nice kind of world rather than
having to do these obtuse kinds of ways
of approach however there are simply
things that you can't nice and neatly
and elegantly do in this straightforward
way you have to appeal to this sort of
reverse tool but it's very elegant to do
so because I'm look at the things you
can prove when you do okay